got to just start off with a couple of
details
1857 it doesn't start off as a
confectionary shop in Belgium it's a
pharmacy what's going on it was a
pharmacist Mr John IH house and in those
days uh medicine was had a very very bad
taste so one day he got the idea of
enrobing the uh bad tasting medicine
with chocolate so at least you had
something that sweeten the pill and then
one day he said instead of taking
something that that has a bad taste let
me make a cream that tastes well and
then robe it with something else
chocolate that tastes well and that is
the origin of the preline so Mr joh n
house actually invented the uh the
preline the preline all right so the
preline is something that is distinctive
to NY house obviously it is more popular
all over the world as well where is the
biggest market now for uh luxury
chocolate amazingly enough for us it
Still Remains Belgium despite the fact
that naos is now available in more than
50 countries but Belgium still can't get
enough of it either and where is the
biggest expansion happening biggest
expansion between Germany between the
United States of course and uh also
Japan and China the different taste do
you have different types of combinations
of taste for different markets some
markets have preferences but on purpose
in the luxury atmosphere we do not adapt
the recipes to countries we want to have
the genuine product distributed all over
the world and that's why we still
produce nio still produces everything in
belgum what characterizes luxury
chocolate as opposed to let's say
ordinary everyday chocolate it's the
uncom uncompromising search for Quality
ingredients and then having the top
chocolateers to be able to put them
together but the and and without any
compromise on top ingredients from is it
getting more difficult to Source the
high-end uh cocoa it is sometimes
difficult as sometimes there are
clarities and sometimes uh there is
speculation but we never give in on that
one now you also have added a kind of
twist when it comes to Whiskey in
chocolate tell us about this well
chocolate is highly gastronomical
product in its top quality and it goes
very well together with a number of
drinks and among others top quality
whiskey and that's how we talking with a
couple of friends at couple of some of
top restaurants uh we said why not do
some together with whiskey and to look
at the pairing between n House chocolate
and whiskey and that's how that passion
started how much should people expect to
spend if they want to buy a box of good
luxury Belgian chocolate uh they would
spend anything between I would say $25
to
$150 do you have a favorite chocolate
most definitely and it's called the
tonion which in English is Temptation it
was a chocolate that was invented for
the world exhibition in Brussels in
1958 we still make it completely by hand
and it's also one of the favorite
chocolates actually of our Royals